-[shouts]
-[patrons gasp]
Yassan!
-[grunts]
-[patrons gasp]
I almost landed my attack this time.
[Yasuke groans]
Stop bothering me.
I don't care.
Ichiro, I told you, no training in my bar.
You're scaring away the customers.
-[groaning]
-[glass shatters]
-[people gasp]
-[Yasuke] Leave the boy alone.
[merchant mutters nervously]
[chuckles]
Guess I'll have
to shut your mouth for you.
-[bystander] Get back, get back!
-[crowd murmurs]
[mellow electronic music playing]
[swordsman grunting]
[both grunting]
[gasps, groans]
-[both grunting]
-[onlookers clamor]
[gasps]
[grunts]
-[music resumes]
-[groaning]
[men gasp]
[grunting]
[gurgling, groaning]
History will forget you!
[general shouts]
[thud]
Saki!
Accept the light of the Lord inside you!
[straining]
[growling]
[screaming]
[straining]
-[screaming]
-[grunts]
[straining]
[loud crack]
[growling]
-[roars]
-[gasps]
Where's the girl?
[Yasuke] Far from here.
I hope for your sake
you fight better than you lie.
[overlapping grunts]
[choked grunt]
[gasps softly]
[yells]
[armored man] Giant!
Drop your weapon and turn slowly.
[woman gasps]
[panting]